Relationships can be tricky.
They're amazing when they're going well but if something happens
and you're on a rocky road, they can be painful.
If you've been with someone a long time, you can start
to get stuck in a routine.
You might not necessarily notice the behavior of the other half
because it's becoming the norm to you.
Taking a step back and looking at your relationship
from a different viewpoint can be really beneficial
and help you gain perspective on a scenario.
There is no perfect relationship.
Even the happiest of couples have arguments,
disagreements, and temporary breakups.
That's life!
But there is a time when you have to look at your relationship
without rose tinted glasses and see if those small arguments
are actually escalating into massive rows
Sometimes you have to leave a relationship and put yourself
first to be happy
So Psych2Go shares
5 signs that tell you when it's time to leave a relationship
1. You're consistently unhappy
Any relationship, be it friends, family, or romantic
should bring you happiness.
You should look forward to seeing your partner
and enjoy spending time with them
Obviously, you can't be consistently happy in a relationship
because that's not realistic
but you should feel supported, safe, and loved.
If you start to feel consistently unhappy,
maybe it's time to ask yourself why.
Maybe it's you or maybe your partner.
It's good to understand why you're feeling unhappy
so you can either fix the problem or choose to leave.
There is no shame to admit that your relationship is not
offering you the same support and contentment
that it once was.
2. You're travelling on different paths.
Sometimes you can start a relationship in one place
but as you grow, you can change mindsets.
Long term relationships can be amazing as you grow
and change with your partner.
But sometimes you can grow and change at a different
rate to your partner.
If you're moving in different directions to your partner,
it can be difficult to navigate a relationship.
Also if you're in a different place emotionally, you might
not want the same things.
In this case it's best for both of you to separate amicably
It's a good thing to discuss what each of you wants from
a relationship if you're going to be serious about a partner.
3. Lack of support.
In a relationship, support is key.
You want to feel that your partner believes in what you're doing.
and is behind you 100%
but if that support isn't there,
you can start to feel let down and unfulfilled.
Emotional support is also really important.
If you're not feeling that in a relationship,
it can be damaging and affect your happiness.
If you don't feel like your partner is invested in you
and is behind you all the way,
then it might be time to consider having a conversation
about your relationship with your partner.
4. Abuse of any sort.
By this I mean emotional, physical, sexual,
financial, and so on.
If your partner has abused you in any way,
then this is a clear sign you should at least consider leaving.
Abuse is very damaging
and the abuser can often try [to] convince you to stay in the relationship
If this is the case, you should leave for your own safety.
It can be very difficult to leave a relationship like that
but there are hotlines available to contact should you need to
Remember, you're not alone in this.
5. Lack of trust.
The foundation of all relationships should be trust.
The trust between you and your partner should be strong.
If it isn't, that could mean you doubt their actions.
As a result, this could possibly lead to jealousy.
If you don't trust your partner, you could work on it and try to rebuild it.
Losing trust is often a sign that something is
wrong within your relationship
and you'll need to address it.
However, if you're past the rebuilding phase,
maybe your partner betrayed your trust too many times.
Ending the relationship could be a possibility.
There is no shame in admitting you can't be with someone
you don't fully trust.
It's all about what makes you happy.